hi there Steve coffin here thought I'd
do another video right on the heels of
my Japanese video there were some
comments to my Japanese video saying
that I'm much more enthusiastic when I
speak in foreign languages or speaking
Japanese I'm going to try to be a little
less monotonous when I speak English
here the Japanese video talked about how
you know it's important for success in
language learning it's important to have
fun with language learning that if it's
drudgery we aren't going to learn and
too often in in language classes it is
drudgery here in Canada they forced kids
to learn the tenses before the kids have
any sense of the language and in Japan
there's this tremendous emphasis on
tests and the bookstores are just full
of manuals on how to ace TOEFL for a
bunch of people at or TOEIC who have
very little sense of the language
because they haven't listened to it
haven't read it so that was my Japanese
video and one of the questions was try
to be enthusiastic here how did I learn
Japanese and so I thought I would do a
quickie on that I haven't really given
it much thought but remember that I was
in Hong Kong where it was my job to
learn Chinese and so there I went at it
literally ten hours a day I had three
hours a day of classroom instruction
one-on-one so I was speaking from day
one and on to get back to that Benny
paradigm I was speaking from day one but
with teachers who were drilling me
initially and then we would have
conversations as soon as I was able to
have conversations and then I would go
home and I would listen and read and I
would work on my characters and and
within three months I was you know
reading the newspaper people's daily and
this kind of thing and and so forth and
and a big part of my learning there was
simply finding things to read because
I've always been convinced that reading
and then if you have the opportunity to
listen to the same content which wasn't
always the case then just let that ring
that's the home phone you know that
enhances the the perception that you're
able to to make obviously it's easier to
read
need them to listen for quite a long
long time so that was my experience with
with Chinese and I met my major emphasis
in Chinese was patterns you know in
Chinese there are patterns I didn't
understand the various grammatical
explanations but you know as in English
you say if you do something then I will
do something or hey you know given the
fact that therefore and so all of these
patterns you know and in Chinese is like
you go not go is how they say are you
going so patterns I wanted to really get
used to the patterns of Chinese so the
reason I ended up in Japan by the way is
that I had a boss in the Canadian called
High Commission Canadian Consulate in
Hong Kong and I had been assigned to
learn Chinese with the goal that I would
go up to Beijing as soon as Canada
recognized or Canada and China establish
diplomatic relations and the person who
was going to be my boss there was my
boss in Hong Kong and I felt that he was
a complete jerk and you know he would do
things like he was very much you know
threatened by the fact that I was
learning Chinese because he was the
resident expert on China and if anyone
important came through Hong Kong he
would send me off for two days to do
research somewhere just so that they
couldn't see that there was somebody
else here who who might know something
about China in addition to him so I said
I'm not going to China with this guy I'm
not going to spend you know two or three
years in a relatively isolated post
which is what maging was in those days
and with a guy who plays these kind of
mind games I said but I will go to Japan
and I will learn Japanese on my own it
won't cost the government a penny
because the government after all paid
for my Chinese learning so with that I
once say it read that I was going to go
to to Japan I bought whatever book I
could find in Hong Kong and I started
reading the book and it had tapes and I
remember the greeting the that they had
in that book was Oh many like if you
meet someone or many kakarrot a Tai Hang
coin is on dmoz that was what I was
confronted
that was how you greet people well never
in Japan in nine years or subsequently
have I ever heard anyone say that but
that was their greeting which is kind of
interesting because ever since then I
have no great sense of belief of
anything to give me in a book but it
doesn't matter I just absorbed it it
doesn't matter so I was reading this
book and I can't remember the name of
the book and then I had a friend who was
at the Japanese Consulate in Hong Kong
who was who wanted to learn English and
we were both Chinese learners so twice a
week we would meet for Chinese lunch
Tuesdays and Thursdays and probably most
of the conversation was in Chinese which
was our common language but we would do
a little bit of English and a little bit
of Japanese so that kind of whet my
appetite
and then I arrived in ha in Japan and
basically what I did was just listen and
read as you know I don't believe in this
idea that you can just arrive somewhere
after looking at a phrase book and go
out and start talking to people I think
that's I just think that's just
impractical you have nothing to say you
don't understand what they're saying
most people have no patience for you
however my goal was to get to a level
where I could talk to people as soon as
possible so I do remember some of the
early material that I read Naga Numa the
nagging uma readers terribly boring but
lots of content all in hiragana because
the first thing you had to do is to
learn the hiragana so reading all of
these and it was extremely boring stuff
but I just went through the until I
couldn't stand it anymore I had the
advantage of being able to read Chinese
characters so text that had a more kanji
and it was actually easier for me the
hiragana was more difficult the katakana
in Japanese is a real pain in the neck I
don't like it I have trouble reading it
I try to avoid it you know because the
katakana is used for foreign words is
used for words that represent the sound
of something like crash or bang
uh so I just skipped those because I'm
not gonna bother like I learned the
hiragana I'll figure out how the kanji
is pronounced in Japanese but the
katakana I just don't even bother with
it I just think it's silly to even have
it
Japanese people get mad at me but I just
didn't bother with it so noggin Ouma was
one and then I can't remember all the
little readers that I would find but
just as I did in Hong Kong I would go to
the bookstore and see what I could find
beginner readers even beginner textbooks
ignore all the grammar ignore all the
exercises just read they read the
dialogue grab some of the patterns that
they'll introduce in each lesson go back
and listen read and so I mean that's
always been my approach to language
learning listen read review words review
review patterns then I can remember some
of the material that I enjoyed listening
to for example is uno owed Oracle which
is a very famous novel by kalibata yeah
so naughty and they I was able to get an
audiobook of that and my family and I
were touring in a zoo and in our little
old car and wherever we went the whole
family had to listen to a zoo no audio
Rico the story and we went to some of
the towns that this group of dancers
visited I also remember I marvelous a
tape set that I found called
Shoah no kioku which was a history of
the events of the Showa era and it
included all kinds of contemporary radio
programs describing all of the events
that happened during the Showa era I
don't know how many times I listened to
that and I didn't understand much at
first and gradually I understood more
and more now unlike the you know Dory
code there was no text so I was relying
on I'm just listening in an ideal
scenario you have text and of course we
live in a more ideal world for learning
today because we can carry out a Life
pod around and me you know I can read on
my iPod I can listen from my iPod
and we've got online dictionaries we are
linked so things are much
about them I mean it was just a matter
of listening and reading and and getting
up the sufficient you know vocabulary
that I worked at the Canadian embassy
and and all of our working life was in
English at the Embassy and of course I
was in no position to speak Japanese to
our you know the business people as a
Trade Commissioner that I was supposed
to be dealing with it but I had an
assistant whose name was Nicky Ozaki and
Nicky Zaki is extremely long-winded
speaks very slowly or I assume he's
still alive I don't know spoke very
slowly and normally said the same thing
about three times so he was the ideal
person to start speaking with so
basically once I had enough vocabulary
that I could start you know with much
hesitation saying some things to Nick he
was my teacher so we would talk you know
we did you know a bit of a conversation
in here we also had to work so that Nick
was kind of my trainer personal trainer
and then after a while I started using
it in different situations and and once
you're launched and speaking while
you're you're off to the races but I
would always continue looking for
readers advance Japanese whatever
because again as with Chinese we didn't
have online dictionaries I didn't want
to look through a dictionary I figured
if I could find all the possible readers
that are out there with glossary and if
I could master that vocabulary I'd be
well on my way and that was the case and
of course I had the advantage that I
could you know fairly quickly read the
newspaper because a lot of the
vocabulary there was similar so if I can
read the newspaper then I can listen to
the news and it's again the same
vocabulary so basically that was it and
over time I got better better obviously
the melodrama you know the soap operas
the movies are much more difficult to
listen to that took me a long time
watching baseball games was my first
introduction to Japanese on television
because you could kind of figure out
what was happening you know so basically
that was it
a lot of listening and reading to get
myself you know ready trying to pick up
on the patterns of the language until I
was able to speak to people and then
once you're able to speak then you can
improve pretty quickly so I hope that is
helpful Thanks